recently
many white celebrities have confessed to
only washing their children sporadically
and uh
as a black person
this troubles me
you know i really want to talk to white
people about it but they're not the most
receptive
you know what they do respond to
black people singing a little song oh
yeah
with mild choreography and matching
outfits what a good idea
hit it
[Music]
it's been a real rough couple of weeks
so much [ __ ] has gone down
california droughts and cosby's
[Music]
some famous people barely paid the kids
but guess what they're not brown
[Applause]
your child smells like blue cheese
you got so much money in your bank
account yeah you smell like a whole lot
of notes
my last man sick brand victory but
refuse to invest in soap with that
backwashing thing we like that
y'all take pride in being gross maybe
you'll listen to the pope
[Music]
smells like blue cheese
[Music]
[Applause]
this detergent will do
make sure it's packed but not too hot
[Music]
20 minutes
[Music]
your child is like cream
[Music]
you